we begin on a monday with an
extraordinarily disturbing story that um
only gets worse or worse as you as you
begin to peel back the layers of the
putrid onion
but um there's a reason we're beginning
here and it's it's not just for shock
value and i'll explain in a minute but
first the new york times reports this an
83 year old brooklyn woman convicted
twice of killing women she lived with
was charged with murder on thursday
after investigators found a head in her
apartment that officials said belonged
to a body discovered in a shopping cart
last week the police first discovered
pieces of the victim miss leiden's
remains in the early hours of march 3rd
when a 911 caller reported that they had
found body parts in a shopping cart
outside of a pawn shop at the corner of
atlantic and pennsylvania avenues in
brooklyn police officers arrived to find
a woman's torso inside a multi-colored
bag with a flower decal
and they also by the way discovered the
um
the the
the killer was uh
rolling around a grocery cart a grocery
store in one of those carts and was
sitting on top apparently of the severed
leg
of uh of the victim
now that's where we're beginning and i
said it only gets worse the deeper you
go so
you know you're in for a bumpy ride with
this as the starting point
it turns out that the suspect last name
marceline
is an actual serial killer having been
twice convicted already of murdering two
other women that we know of on two
separate occasions so the times
continues miss marcelin has served
decades in state prison in connection
with two manhattan homicides in 1963 and
1984. in october 1963 she was convicted
of first-degree murder for fatally
shooting her then girlfriend in a harlem
apartment building
the state court judge overseeing the
case imposed a life sentence after the
jury was unable to decide whether to
impose the death penalty court filings
show in may 1984 miss marceline was
released from prison on lifetime parole
according to state records less than a
year later after a body was found in a
bag near central park manhattan
prosecutors said ms martin had stabbed
to death another woman that she had been
living with in 1986 she pleaded guilty
to first-degree manslaughter were
sentenced to six to 12 years in prison
state records show because of her parole
status that sentence was added to the
original life term over the next three
decades she repeatedly sought release on
parole and was denied in a 1997
appearance before the state parole board
ms martin described the 1984 crime and
said she had problems with women
in 2010 the state denied another bid for
parole
saying your release at this time is
incompatible with the welfare and safety
of the community but then she was
released on parole in 2019 record show
okay so
marceline
killed a woman
first degree murder
sentenced to life in prison but was
released after 20 years
marceline kills another woman
is sentenced to prison
added on to the original life sentence
is released again
even though the parole board had
previously said that it would be unsafe
for society if we release you they
released them anyway
and then and then the killer proceeds to
kill and dismember a third victim
that we know of
so apparently big shocker here a serial
killer does not magically become less
dangerous and less deranged after
sitting in a cage for a few decades
there does not arrive a point where you
can say well this deranged lunatic
psychopath killer has been stewing in
solitary confinement for 18 years i'm
sure they're normal now right
that doesn't doesn't happen it doesn't
work that way
um and yet the killer was released again
to kill again but we're missing one
detail here
so you've um you've probably already
maybe noted something you thought
probably well a female serial killer
that's that's unusual it's not unheard
of but it's unusual
you don't hear very many of those
and a female serial killer who targets
women now now that probably is unheard
of
but then the new york times offers this
detail
miss marcelin who was listed as male in
earlier court records but now identifies
as a woman according to a law
enforcement official was indicted on
second-degree murder charges on thursday
in the death of susan lydon uh accused
of dismembering her and hiding her body
parts okay so
this demented psychopath who dismembers
women also happens to have a fetish
where he likes to pretend to be a woman
and the new york times not to mention
the cops the court system
everybody
they're all making sure to respect
this lunatic's delusional fetish and
even participate in it
this is some straight up buffalo bill
silence of the lamb stuff
where this guy likes to kill women and
essentially assume their identity
it should be very clear to any rational
person that his quote gender identity in
this case is all part and parcel with
the whole psychopathic routine
and even if it isn't i mean even if his
masquerading as a woman has nothing to
do with his murder of women even if even
if he developed these two uh quirks
independently
still why should we care to respect his
pronouns
the whole argument for respecting
someone's pronouns is that we don't want
to hurt their feelings i think that's a
bad argument
in general
but for a serial killer
we're actually worried about hurting his
feelings
now this is one example
an extreme example
uh but also not unprecedented of a
problem that permeates our society
which is that
we don't tell people no
you know we're not allowed to say no
anymore nobody says no we're so allergic
to know
that we won't even say it to a damn
serial killer who asks us to affirm his
alleged gender identity a gender
identity that it just so happens
will presumably mean that this killer of
women will now be put in a women's
prison
again any reasonable person can see that
this is almost certainly why he's
calling himself a woman so that he could
be housed with women
his prey of choice
and rather than saying no we're not
doing that you're going to a male prison
you freaking lunatic
the instead of the court system will say
well okay we respect that i mean we
don't approve of other things you've
done but we'll respect you here
they won't tell them no the parole board
wouldn't tell them no
the parole board told him uh you're
dangerous to society but uh okay you can
go
now the media won't tell him no the
police won't tell him the prison system
won't tell him no
this guy should get a no delivered to
him by a firing squad but he won't get
that either
nobody wants to say no and we see this
problem all over society not just with
transgender serial killers
on friday we played a clip of a morbidly
obese plus size model test holiday model
in quotes there i put model in quotes
the same way we've got to put woman in
quotes when talking about the serial
killer but um this plus-sized
quote-unquote model who who though
clearly weighing somewhere in the
neighborhood of 400 pounds claims to be
anorexic and attends weekly therapy
sessions with a counselor who affirms
that perception you know she apparently
thinks that that that when she's when
she's chowing down the two seconds
between bites
count as deprivation and starvation
like i'm anorexic because i'm not
literally eating it literally every
second of the day
that's what she thinks and she's
affirmed in that view she's told yes she
she goes to a dietician
a dietitian once a week
her dietitian should be well telling her
to go on a diet
but diets mean less food and that means
telling her no and you can't do that
everywhere you look you see people who
have never been told no
you see the the plump fruit of our
culture's refusal to say no our
obsession with affirmation
every person you see walking around with
purple hair and a million piercings
demanding to be referred to as they or
zur or
or zeus or whatever is yet another
testament to our unfortunate habit of
affirming everyone in everything all the
time
speaking of people who should be told no
i'm currently in atlanta preparing to
speak to uh at georgia tech tonight in
the lead up to the women's swimming
championships where biological male leah
thomas will compete
now i'll be talking among other things
about the beauty and value of the word
no now leah thomas is obviously not a
serial killer but he benefits from the
extreme ideologically fueled
permissiveness
in our culture and the primary victims
of that relentless affirmation happen to
also be women
i'll be speaking up in protest of his
participation and also to explain why
it's wrong
and to make some points that go beyond
sports because this isn't about sports
fundamentally this is really about truth
and about
learning to say no
no to the nonsense because we all know
that it is nonsense even most of of them
on the left know that it's nonsense
and yet we're supposed to cooperate with
it anyway we're supposed to abandon all
at once the fundamental truth that all
of us know
and have always known
and and we're supposed to do it for no
other reason than the fact that it will
hurt leah thomas's feelings if we don't
and of course his feelings are the only
feelings that matter
his feelings and the feelings of other
trans people i guess i should clarify i
say we don't tell people no anymore it's
only certain people we don't say no to
if you belong to certain categories you
don't get to know
now the other women on his team they get
they get a no
because because his feelings for some
reason are supposed to outweigh the
feelings of women who don't want their
sports destroyed who don't want their
privacy invaded who don't want their
very identities appropriated and stolen
and cheapened and turned into a
costume
the feelings of a million women
are dust
when stacked up against the feelings of
one gender confused man
all of reality is dust
the truth is dust biology everything all
of it is to be discarded for one trans
person's feelings
well i think the answer to that should
be no
i urge everyone to say no don't affirm
what you know are lies don't cooperate
with what you know is wrong
don't abandon what you know is true
don't pretend to believe what you don't
believe
it takes some courage to say no in this
world it's a word that's not said nearly
enough
a word that a guy like leah thomas has
probably never heard in his life
but he needs to hear it all of the
gender ideologues need to hear it
all of the liars and frauds trying to
push and coerce and shame us
into surrendering our common sense
in so many areas of life
all of the cry bullies using emotional
blackmail because they have no arguments
everyone demanding that we pretend to
believe what we don't believe
pretend what is true what is not true
all of them everywhere need to hear it
no
that's the word
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content